- And I worked at Barneys, New
York, the original Barney's
in New York-- it's the title.
- That's fancy.
I had no business working there.
I had to like borrow clothes.
I had to shop at discount stores
to look nice enough to work
at Barneys, New York.
- [Kelly] That's kind of funny and ironic.
- Yes.
(audience laughing)
- You should buy this.
- [Guest] Yes.
I mean, I'm not wearing it.
- Exactly.
- So I worked at Barneys during the day,
and then I worked at the
comedy club at night.
The cool thing about
working at Barney's is that
it became this like, place for me.
It was sort of like a-- (stammering)
gauge of how I was doing
in life or something.
And like the first time
I kind of had any money,
I would like shopped there.
It was kind of a cool thing to be like,
I used to work here and
now I can afford something.
- Amen.
- And then it was an even
kind of like bigger deal.
One day I was shopping
there and the security guard
came over and he was like,
I just want you to know
there are paparazzi outside.
First of all, the security
guard like recognized me
was like a moment, and
that he was like worried
about my paparazzi, you know.
- That's amazing.
- I know!
And he was like, I'll walk you to the car.
And I was like, thanks.
(audience laughing)
I'm so worried.
(Kelly clapping)
I'm so concerned for my safety.
(Kelly laughing)
So, I finished my shopping
and I, you know, I was like
thank you so much, sir.
I'm ready to go to the car.
And he like walks me out
to the car and nobody took my picture.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God, was someone else there?
- So I like get in my car.
And he was like so confused.
And I was, I was like,
Oh they must not be here for me.
And he's like, well, yeah,
Gwen Stephani is also here.
- Oh my gosh, that's awesome!
(audience laughing)
- And it was real moment.
Cause I was like, Oh, well I
guess it's not quite there.
- I've been offered a job.
In like an interior design place.
I was doing things to my
thing, and the lady goes,
do you have, do you
need like a second job?
Or like any-- and she
had no idea who I was.
And I was like flattered
because she liked my taste.
At the same time I was like,
still haven't quite made it.
She doesn't know who I am.
(Kelly and guest laughing)
I was like, cool.
Anyway, I could keep
going with those moments.